ja ich freue mich heute ganz besonders
diabetiker nur zu dürfen ist gemacht
psychologen und sehr gute lösung wir was
ist denn das große ganze
ich denke dass das böse er so ein
ethischer oder theologischer begriff ist
und für mich gibt es als böse taten und
die würde ich persönlich zu springen
definieren als raten nach der abwägung
kosten-nutzen anderen hohe kosten
erzeugen
neben mensch den kauf um sich selbst
einen nutzen zu verkaufen also streng
genommen sehr egoistische entscheidungen
gibt es natürlich im kleinen wie im
großen
würdest du sagen das ist also trados
stufen des bösen zu ganz kleine stufen
und ein bisschen durch genießen also
dieser theorie dass für mich das böse
definiert wird durch verhaltensweisen
die hat bestimmte effekte haben
bestimmte menschen würde ich halt sagen
wenn die kosten für die anderen menschen
deutlich höher sind als der nutzen den
es eigentlich für diese person hat oder
wenn diese person einfach entscheidet
anderen menschen kosten auch zu zwingen
wie sie gar nicht wollen und auch gleich
feuer sehen können ist das natürlich
eine böse handlung also eine sehr
rationale kostenlos abgeben haben das
noch meine persönliche definition
ich weiß aber dass alle menschen in der
lage sind gute und böse entscheidungen
zu treffen und auch menschen die sehr
böse falten zeigen weil ich mal auch
gute verhaltensweisen zeigen und
umgekehrt also gute und böse
eigenschaften und falls zwei sind
flecken in allen menschen mit
unterschiedlichem ausmaß du würdest du
sagen es gibt generell die neuen gang
zum bösen vielleicht kann sagt er eine
zu genießen
nein ich arbeite ja in meinem begriffen
wenig wie gesagt mit so was wir haben
zu lösen sondern eher ich sagt manche
menschen haben eine größere
wahrscheinlichkeit entscheidungen zu
treffen mit denen sie andere schädigen
weil sie der meinung sind dass sie mit
ihrer bedürfnisbefriedigung sich das
recht nach schaffen und sich auch das
recht zugestehen sozusagen dem anderen
schaden zufügen die eigene bedürfnisse
zu befriedigen
das wäre meine definition frau
entscheidet sich was böse menschen haben
eher bremsenden sich nicht um diese
bremsen wenn die ferien
es ist einfacher eine böse entscheidung
zu treffen im sinne von anderen zu
schaden weil die person hat für sich
weniger kosten
wenn du jemandem und beklaut und wurst
ist mit einem guten gewissen eine sehr
stark ausgeprägten wir wissen dann wirst
du dich schuldig fühlen schuldig fühlen
ist ein schlechtes gefühl es erzeugt
also bei dir kosten und die kosten wie
du hätte ist nicht schuldig zu fühlen
und angst vor strafe ihren posten eben
nicht in kauf nehmen möchte ist und
deswegen würdest du dich wahrscheinlich
eher entscheiden ist nichts zu tun
ein mensch aber diese kosten nicht
empfindet weil es weder fisch noch ein
sportler hat aber den gewinn sieht du
hast die chance natürlich größer dass er
sich entscheidet diese egoistische
handlungen zugegeben nicht mehr ein
jetzt bist du auch kriminalpsychologe
habe mir hast du gerne alltag mit bösen
menschen zu tun
ich hab halt menschen weniger als böse
menschen weil ich wie gesagt der meinung
wir dass alle menschen gute und böse
anteile haben wenn auch manche menschen
sicherlich mehr egoistische anteile
haben jemand als böse definieren kann
damit man das will
aber ich glaube es gibt weder einen
menschen der abgrundtiefen nur böse ist
und gibt es keinen menschen der wirklich
absolut nur gut ist
ich habe halt immer diese verschiedenen
anteile und ich arbeite ja mit menschen
die straftaten begehen und das sind
natürlich lebensweisen durch die andere
massiv geschädigt werden wenn es zu
schweren straftaten sind das heißt jeder
mensch tut dinge die kosten für andere
erzeugen weil er in diesem augenblick
halt seinen bedürfnissen nachgehen kann
man diese menschen mit die richtigen
häufig in gewissen schlechtes gewissen
finden kann irgendwie heimkam therapiert
na ja erstens nicht alle menschen nicht
nachlassen wir gehen haben ein defizit
in gewissens instanzen es gibt auch
viele möglichkeiten einen gewissen zu
umgehen das ist vielleicht noch
interessanter aber jemand der wenig
gewissen hat aufgrund seiner schweren
persönlichkeitsstörungen
der wird auch später keinen gewissen
empfinden also eher schlechtes gewissen
der kann aber rational lernen sich
anders zu steuern unter anderem aus
egoistischen sehr sehr vereinfacht
gesagt jemand der wirklich sehr wenig
grip übergangs hat kann sich sagen im
gefängnis zu leben ist relativ gut ist
viel fremdbestimmt wenig freiheit
wirklich möglichkeiten etwas eigenes zu
tun
also sagt dass ich wenn er nicht sein
ganzes leben inhaftiert verbringen
möchte dann wäre es besser für ihn würde
lernen andere strategien zu entwickeln
aus egoistischen gründen kann sich ein
mensch also durchaus entscheiden sich
sozialer zur wahl
es wäre natürlich die philosophie
sprache ist da nämlich jetzt ein guter
mensch oder zeigt der gute
verhaltensweisen aber genau so
egoistisch der effekt ist aber für seine
umwelt besser als vorher
ja das ist die philosophie ich bin ganz
froh dass ich da kein fieber sockeln das
nicht so entscheiden muss und dann gibt
es auch menschen die dem gewissen haben
und mit kognitiver verzerrung ihren
gewissen um jedem ganz ganz böses
beispiel weil die leute wollte man alles
nur mörder hören
aber möglichst wenig oder das böse thema
kindesmissbrauch das ist immer so als
ich mir bloß nichts davon das ist ganz
schlimm viele menschen die kinder
missbrauchen haben eine gewissens
instanz wie sie mit kognitiven
verzerrungen umgehen
wir haben also gedanken konstrukte um
sich eine rechtfertigung zu verschaffen
damit sie ihr gewissen nicht spüren dass
leute mir sehr ein weil man bekannten
gebe ich mich sehr geschickt und den
denn dieses phänomen ist vernünftig
da ist so eine ordnung zu konstruieren
in der halbleiter- werden eigenen maxime
behandlungen als gerechtfertigt
erscheinen wurde
ja da haben doch viele nehmen eine
letzte warnung
würdest du sagen dass die menschheit
sich unter summe zum es aber würdest du
sagen es bleibt gleich oder wird sie
sogar schlechter jetzt in diesem kosten
nutzen kalkül dass die volks ja in der
summe ist das schwer objektiv zu
beurteilen
die menschheit alle menschen auf dem
globus in allen kulturen in allen
ländern unter allen bedingungen kannst
du ähnlich so als gesamt zur subsumieren
ja ich glaube dass menschen heutzutage
mehr technische möglichkeiten haben und
in einigen ländern auch fortschritte auf
das ethische entscheidungen angeht wir
sind ja von dem auge-um-auge -prinzip
normalen weg zu anderen prinzip wird
also auch die ethischen vorstellungen
haben uns weiterentwickelt die
aufklärung war sehr wichtig für
humanistische werde und sie weiter nur
zwei punkte
ja das war ein einschlag der danach
natürlich werte findet dass wir heute
sich noch heute besonders ethisch
orientieren wollten schlechte karten
aber die
die effekte des umdenkens geben jetzt
wieder schritte zurück und man kriegt so
ein bisschen den eindruck als würde sich
die menschen gerade in ihrer phase
wieder ein bisschen zurück entwickeln
also ich denke es ist ein prozess von
lernen und dann wäre ein schritt zurück
und dann wieder schritte vor und zurück
und das über viele generationen also
unsere generation ist minimaler
ausschnitt und da ja ich kann keine
prognose abgeben für die zukunft und
auch bisher so wirklich werden wird aber
mein optimistisch mein optimismus hält
sich in grenzen weil prinzipiell glaube
ich die chancen dass menschen immer am
ende egoistisch sind und dass sie nicht
dafür sorgen werden dass ist eine ganze
generation gut jetzt ich wollte noch
einen wichtigen punkt sagen wenn man
verbrechensprävention machen will müsste
man eigentlich dafür sorgen dass schon
kinder in einem guten umfeld aufwachsen
prävention fängt eigentlich an in
familien
man müsste also ein zwei generationen
lang dafür sorgen dass familien
funktionieren dass kinder nicht
misshandelt werden auch nicht emotional
körperlich nicht sexuell nicht aber auch
emotional hätte man nach zwei
generationen viel weniger verbrechen
man könnte so positiven effekt erzeugen
das wird aber niemals passieren weil
niemals irgendwelche regierungen zeigen
als wir voraus denken so funktionieren
legislaturperioden nicht deswegen können
wir diese hoffnung eigentlich begraben
und von daher mein optimismus bezüglich
der menschheit ist sehr gering
vielen dank für diesen aufschlussreichen
gedanken zum problem des bösen damit
sind wir am ende bei philips die
verabschieden bis zur nächsten sitzung